guten abend herr wir haben gerade gehört
die justizministerin
guten abend die justizministerin hat
ihre meinung jetzt auch etwas geändert
ist das ein gutes zeichen dafür dass es
jetzt doch klappt mit der
gesetzesverschärfung seit einem jahr
arbeiten wir daran unter signal von
heute ist schon ein interessantes signal
ein gutes signal aber es kommt natürlich
jetzt aufs kleingedruckte an auf die
details zum beispiel bei
kinderpornografie wenn nur
kinderpornografie stärker als wir
besprechen bestraft werden soll wenn es
gewerbsmäßig betrieben doch dann sage
ich ihnen dann ist das interessant und
nett das hilft uns aber nicht denn die
großen fälle die wir alle in nordrhein
westfalen hatten da war gar kein geld im
spiel und beim kindesmissbrauch da muss
sicher sein dass egal was da an schlaf
stärke es das strafmaß muss klar ein
verbrechens maßstab sein
wissen sie ich kann nicht akzeptieren
dass kinder missbraucht werden und das
behandelt wird wie ladendiebstahl das
ist vergleichbar wie macht nicht
körperlichen und mord aber physischen ja
das sehen natürlich viele menschen in
deutschland auf so fragen sich deswegen
auch wie weit sind wir dennoch weg von
einer gesetzesverschärfung wie weit ist
der weg tatsächlich nach nämlich sicher
heute aber glauben schritt gemacht weil
die bundespolizisten ministerin das
problem anerkannt hat und erklärt hat
sie würde sich in die richtung bewegen
aber trotzdem ich sage ihnen ich habe so
viel erlebt in den letzten jahren
jetzt muss man genau gucken wie der text
aussieht und ich werde nicht offen bevor
nicht klar ist wenn möglich an kindern
vergeht der wird als verbrecher bestraft
punkt ja wie lange ist der weg noch bis
zu ein gesetz wird mit einer
verschärfung dann durch ist genau das
haben wir gerade auch noch mal in
hannover die spd chefin saskia esken
gefragt kommt dieses gesetz noch vor der
sommerpause wollten wir wissen
[Musik]
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen nicht
gesagt aber möglich also dass wir haben
in den letzten in den letzten wochen
monaten erlebt wie schnell politik gehen
können ganz neue erfahrung das ist man
ja ehrlich sagen also ich habe es gerade
gehört vor der sommerpause rechnet sie
nicht mehr damit und sie haben es auch
gerade schon gesagt es ist momentan eher
wie diebstahl ladendiebstahl obwohl es
eine tat ist mit der die opfer ihr leben
lang
ja das verarbeiten müssen und damit
leben müssen wenn sie jetzt wieder neue
fälle hören gerade aktuell in
nordrhein-westfalen der fall solingen
was ist das erste was ihnen durch den
kopf geht gott sei dank kann man wieder
einen erwischt gott sei dank wird ein
kind wieder vom missbrauch befreit
diese normalerweise als in list fürchtet
man sich vor jedem neuen fall aber in
dem bereich kindesmissbrauch bin ich für
jeden fall den wir aufdecken wieder froh
weil genau das wollten wir erreichen wir
wollten die kinder und vor allem wie die
täter aus der dunkelheit rausholen
sie sind also froh dass aufgedeckt ist
man aber auch nicht fassungslos darüber
wie lange es trotzdem gedauert hat wie
lange dieser missbrauch stattfinden
konnte tja das problem ist nicht so ganz
einfach erstens wir haben in münster
gelernt dass es dabei auch täter gibt
die technik an since experten sind und
ihre daten so extrem verschlüsseln
zweitens wir haben eine solchen berg an
daten im internet das kann sich ja gar
keiner vorstellen dass sie nicht 1000
das sind terabyte an daten und die
können nicht polizisten selbst wenn sie
1000 hätten an einem tag alle durch
gruppen das dauert und dass wir brauchen
unsere mischung aus mehr polizisten wir
haben jetzt 400 mehrheit also insgesamt
vervierfacht unsere anzahl an polizisten
und wir brauchen technologie uns läuft
damit es schneller geht also wenn da
auch ja sagen müssen zu künstlichen
intelligenz und anderen herr römer merkt
dieses thema ist wichtig für sie es
bewegt sie und so geht es auch uns auch
hierbei gilt deswegen wollen wir den
druck nicht nachlassen wir wollen dass
es schärfere gesetze gibt aber wir
fragen uns auch warum dauert es
überhaupt so lange ein gesetz anzupassen
in diesem fall zu verschärfen
das frage ich mich manchmal auch wenn
man vor allem bedenken wie viele wie
lange wieder daran schon was sind und
ich habe erlebt in der letzten zeit wenn
es ganz eng wird der kriegt die politik
auch gesetze im schnellverfahren hin
ganz schnell also schnellverfahren im
richtigen sinne natürlich
und ich würde mir schon wünschen würde
jetzt wo das thema klar ist und wenn vom
justizminister und der meinung des
bekannten es machen sie wäre auch der
meinung dann finde ich hier schneller
hier besser
das sehen wir bei bild genauso vielen
dank herr minister rolle